three of germany's political parties
have struck a deal to govern together
despite their differences the so-called
traffic light coalition named after the
party colours includes
the center-left demo social democrats
the greens and the liberal fdp they aim
to strengthen germany's role on the
international stage and do more to
tackle the climate crisis now the
parties have agreed to introduce a 12
euro minimum wage the coalition wants to
phase out coal by 2030 they also want to
legalize the sale of cannabis which
could bring in billions of euro in texas
and they aim to build 400 000 new homes
a year
to ease a housing shortage
now here's a look at how the day
unfolded in berlin
for the first time since the social
democrats won the election two months
ago germans were given a clear roadmap
for the future
three parties who have never governed
together have reached a lengthy
agreement on how to run europe's largest
economy despite their differences
we're not interested in the politics of
the lowest common denominator instead
we're interested in great impacts we
want to have the ambition to do
something about climate protection about
the restructuring of our industry about
the modernization of the country about
the strengthening of social cohesion
we want to dare to achieve more progress
perhaps the biggest announcement was the
formation of a new ministry combining
climate and the economy to be headed by
robert habeck of the greens
no longer a fringe issue the new
coalition promises to put the climate at
the forefront of its policy
considerations
modernizing a country in a time of
crisis means a huge effort and a great
deal of determination will be needed
we've now laid the basis for this effort
and determination
at the heart of this new story that we
can write together is the compatibility
of prosperity and climate protection
but that is not the only crisis
threatening germany and the european
union
the incoming government says it wants to
put european foreign policy first in
dealing with problems in its own
backyard
we're tackling this common challenge at
a time when the crisis in our immediate
vicinity here in the middle of europe
are becoming more severe
the challenges are becoming more
difficult
if we look at the situation in belarus
or the situation at europe's external
borders that is why we have agreed
together to return to an active european
foreign policy
the agreement addressed domestic needs
as well such as affordable housing the
need to improve germany's vaccination
rate as another coveted winter
approaches
and digital
the younger generation in particular has
given us a mandate to overcome this
status quo of the past years
schultz is expected to be named
chancellor on december 8th
then it will be up to him and the rest
of the coalition to put the plan into
action
let's bring in our chief uh political
editor michelle kufner for more uh
michelle it's clear that the new
government coalition partners uh they've
got ambitious plans to to change germany
into a greener more efficient and
progressive society do you have any
better ideas about how they'll put that
into action
well certainly on the key issue of
climate they are creating a super
ministry
a trade and climate ministry that will
be headed by the green co leader robert
harbeck
and that will
bundle a lot more competencies but
behind all of that speak is still the
big question where the money will be put
and that's firmly in the hands of the
pro-business free democrats and that's
where we have the inbuilt divide right
there we don't know how much will be
earmarked in the new budget for which
ministry at the same time
we heard a lot less writing and talk
about international ambitions than in
the past agreement and at that press
conference that's what i put to the
incoming chancellor olaf choice just
let's take a look at that clip
for an international audience in english
if i may mr schultz
during the last coalition you were vice
chancellor europe was at the very top of
that last coalition deal now foreign
policy starts at page 142.
how will
german foreign policy change
and where will you start as chancellor
or maybe also if you want to mention who
the foreign minister will be
deutsche
germany stands by its responsibility
within the framework of the european
union
we're a large country in the middle of
europe that's committed to the task of
making the european union better every
day
making it work better
we are not standing on the sidelines
commenting but we want to play our part
in making a strong sovereign europe
possible
and we are aware of our deep
transatlantic ties in particular our
cooperation with the us
this will be central to our future
government
michelle i want to ask you about the uh
the contest for cabinet positions during
the negotiations what does it um tell
you about how how different
these parties really are
well it tells me that some tough
decisions had to be made for instance
the transport ministry didn't go to the
greens that's something they're already
getting quite a bit of fire over from
their own party base and they will have
to put this whole marriage contract of
the coalition to the party grassroots
that will be continuing over the coming
days and the week after next we will
then most likely
see olaf shorts sworn in and we're still
to learn who the names are on the social
democrat side
they are the strongest party that is
also reflected but we saw the weakest
party get four of those ministries at
least two can be considered key
that demonstrates that a delicate
balance here is being struck as this
coalition already heads into its first
baptism of fire which is the current
covert crisis here in germany and
growing public frustration that
politicians both the current caretaker
government and the incoming coalition
are too slow and not effective enough at
responding to this michelle it's been 16
years of angela merkel olive schultz is
set to become chancellor you've reported
on both of them extensively but just
tell us a little bit about what kind of
a leader olive schultz is going to be
well he still is
angela mackel's vice chancellor in the
coalition he has learnt from angela
merkel how to do chancellor to a certain
degree um people close to him say that
he's reliable but he's also good at
affording compromises and sticking to
them he is a rather softly spoken man
you saw in that clip there he doesn't
come across as sparkly or charismatic as
some other world leaders but he
certainly knows a lot of them and he
just won an election by coming across
rather macholesce so i think it's the
maximum continuity one can expect from
the other side of that current coalition
all right that's dw's chief political
editor talking to us there thank you
michelle as always